opposers this can't wait everyone's
talking about this royal wedding between
Prince Harry and Megan Markel but not me
I don't need to look across the pond for
entertainment believe me I've tried
there's no the pond is just an entire
ocean misleading
we don't need Prince Harry no we have
our own favorite royal son Jared Kushner
and he's way better than Harry in every
single way I mean listen to Harry speak
I managed to persuade her to come and
join me we come town with each other
under the stars
Oh nails on a chalkboard right Jared on
the other hand my name is Jared Kushner
pure butter and what does Harry even do
oh that's right nothing
Jared meanwhile is in charge of peace in
the Middle East and last I checked
mission accomplished
Harry lives in a castle meanwhile Jared
has a skyscraper in Manhattan that no
one will buy you do the math and as for
making Marco what's she famous for the
TV show suits on the USA Network ah
well our princess of vodka makes suits
via the China Network and they hold up
pretty well the first three or four
times you wear them case closed so yeah
enjoy the royal wedding I'll be hate
tweeting about her tres Jesus stunning
those are both modern and traditional at
the same time but America first
[Music]